have you ever wondered why the ultra  wealthy buy paintings like this for 75.1  million or 137.5 million or 43.8 million  it's not about the art most of the time  it's about evading taxes legally number  one become a billionaire and get slapped  in the face with a giant tax bill number  two buy a 10 million dollar painting  number three store in what's called a  freeport so you don't have to pay any  sales tax number four the gallery will  pump up the value of your painting using  their influence in the art world boom  here 10 million dollar painting is now  worth 50 million  number five donate that painting to a  museum number six write out the 50 ml as  a charitable donation and boom you just  made 40 mil by spending 10 10ml